a federal judge is threatening to hold
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and other
officials in contempt but so far there's
been no reaction from the Justice
Department judge Emmett Sullivan said it
was unacceptable for the government to
deport a mother and daughter during a
court hearing on their request for
asylum he ordered their plane to return
to the United States immediately
Matea Vario is outside the detention
center in Dili Texas where the two have
now returned
Matea good morning good morning we are
just off a busy highway and were being
kept about a quarter of a mile from the
facility here in Dili Texas now this is
the largest us family detention center
it houses both mothers and children and
right now the attorneys for the mother
in this particular case who goes by the
name Carmen says that she was facing
gang death threats and an abusive
husband the South Texas family
residential center in Dili Texas seen
here in video shot by US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement has been home for
Carmen and her little girl for weeks
the mother was here while fighting the
denial of her asylum request she's part
of a lawsuit filed by the ACLU
challenging what they say are the Trump
administration's more restrictive Asylum
policies she fled to this country
seeking safety but instead she was
denied a chance to apply for asylum and
she was denied a fair hearing for her
claims the court believed the government
had agreed to keep them in the u.s.
until midnight Thursday as a judge held
an emergency hearing instead during the
proceeding the judge learned US
officials had put the pair on a flight
back to El Salvador my heart sank
immediately in a written order the judge
scolded Attorney General Jeff Sessions
and demanded Carmen and her daughter be
sent back to the United States
sources confirm the mother and daughter
never got off the plane in El Salvador
and headed back to the facility in Dili
Texas Thursday CBS News was given a
first-hand look at the detention center
which holds roughly 1500 mothers and
children about ten percent of them were
once separated but have been reunited I
think the reason this place was set up
is so that we could actually bring those
people through this island
and get a final decision on what their
case is like still legal advocates
working with these families say the
criteria for deciding who stays and who
gets deported is vague we are fighting
for them to all have their fair day in
court
now the Carmen and her daughter will be
heading back here to the facility in
Dili Texas it is expected that the judge
will start to speed up their case we
also reached out to the Department of
Justice and have yet to hear back from
them all right Maria thank you